fiber to the home  is fast becoming the world's most widely  deployed broadband solution  as we look forward optical fiber will be  the keystone component  that will enable the access network of  tomorrow  this access network will support  applications that require  high bandwidth and low latency  these applications will drive  transformational change  in how we all live work and play  the upcoming fiber to home conference is  a unique opportunity then  to share and learn how we will make this  transition to an all optical  access network happen corning as a  founding member of the fibreville home  council  is proud to participate and sponsor this  important event  i look forward to engaging with you all  in december  albeit virtually to take forward our  fiber future  together